hi I'm an engineer and I make robots and
of course you all know what a robot is
right if you don't you probably go to
Google and you'd ask Google what a robot
is so let's do that we'll go to Google
and this is what we get now you can see
how that lots of different types of
robots but they're predominantly
humanoid in structure and they look
pretty conventional because they got
plastic they got metal
they've got motors and gears and so on
some of them look quite friendly and you
could go up and you could hug them some
of them not so friendly they look like
they're straight out of terminated in
fact they might well be straight out of
terminator now you can do lots of really
cool things with these robots we could
have really exciting stuff but I'd like
to look at different kinds of robots
I want to make different kinds of robots
and I take inspiration from the things
that don't look like us they look like
these so this is natural biological
organisms and they just really cool
things that we can't and current robots
can't either so they do all sorts of
great things like moving around on the
floor they go into our gardens and they
eat our crops they climb trees they grow
water they come out of water they trap
insects and digest them so it's a really
interesting things they live they
breathe they die they eat things from
the environment our current robots don't
really do that now wouldn't it be great
if you could use some of those
characteristics in future robots so that
you could solve some really interesting
problems so I'm going to look at a
couple of problems now in the
environment where we can use the skills
and the technologies derived from these
animals and from the plants and we can
use them to solve those problems let's
have a look at two environmental
problems there both of our making this
is man interacting with the environment
and doing some rather unpleasant things
the first one is to do with the pressure
of population such as the pressure of
population around the world that
agriculture and farming is required to
produce more
more crops now to do that farmers but
more and more chemicals onto the land
they put on fertilizers nitrates
pesticides all sorts of things encourage
the growth of the crops but there's a
negative impact what are the negative
impacts is if you've got lots of
fertilizer on the land not all of it
goes into the crops
lots of it stays in the in the soil and
then when it rains these chemicals go
into the water table and in the water
table then they go into streams into
lakes into rivers and into the sea now
you put all these chemicals these
nitrates into those kind of environments
there are organisms in those
environments that will be affected by
that algae for example now he loves
nitrates it loves fertilizer soda
taking all these chemicals and if the
conditions are right it'll mass produced
it will produce masses and masses of new
algae that's called a bloom the trouble
is that went out he reproduces like this
it starves the water of oxygen as soon
as you do that the other organisms in
the water can't survive so what do we do
we try to produce a robot that will eat
the algae consume it and make it safe so
that's the first problem the second
problem is also of our making and it's
to do with oil pollution now oil comes
out of the engines that we use the boats
that we use sometimes tankers flush
their oil tanks into the sea so oil is
released into the sea that way wouldn't
it be nice if we could treat that in
some way using robots that could eat the
pollution the oil fields have produced
so that's what we do we make robots that
will eat pollution now to actually make
the robot we take inspiration from two
organisms so on the right there you see
the basking shark and the basking shark
is a massive shark its non-carnivorous
so you can swim with it as you can see
and the basking shop opens its mouth and
it swims through the water collecting
plankton as it does that it digests the
food and then it uses that energy and
its body to keep moving so quickly make
a robot like man like the basking shark
let's chug through the water and
eet's of pollution well let's see if we
can do that but also we take the
inspiration from other organisms so I'm
going to picture here of a water boatman
and the water boatman is really cute
when it's swimming in the water it uses
its paddle like legs to push itself
forward so we take those two organisms
and we combine them together to make a
new kind of robot in fact because we're
using the water boatman its inspiration
and our robot sits on top of the water
and it rose we call it the robot okay so
a robot is a robot that rose okay so
what does it look like here are some
pictures of the robot and you'll see it
doesn't look anything like the robots we
saw right at the beginning so Google is
wrong
robots don't look like that they look
like this so I've got the robots here I
just pulled up for you it gives you a
sense of the scale and it doesn't look
anything like the others okay so it's
made out of plastic and we have a look
now at the components that make up the
robot what makes it really special so
the robot is made up of three parts and
those three parts are really like the
parts of any organism it's got a brain
it's got a body and it's got a stomach
it needs the stomach to create the
energy so any robot will have those
three components and any organism will
have those three components so let's go
through them one at a time so it has a
body and its body is made out of plastic
and it sits on top of the water and it's
got it's got flippers on the society
paddles that help it move just like the
water boatman it's got a plastic body
it's got soft rubber mouth mouth here
and a mouth here it's got two mouths why
does it have two mouths well one is to
let the food go in and the other is to
let the food go out so you can see
really it's got a mouth under derriere
or a something where the stuff comes out
which is just like a real organism so
it's starting to look like that basking
shark so that's the body second
component might be the stomach we need
to get the energy into the robot and we
need to treat the pollution so pollution
goes in and it will do something so it's
got a cell in the middle here called a
microbial fuel cell
is down now lift up the fuel cell here
so instead of having batteries instead
of having conventional power system it's
got one of these this is its stomach and
it really is a stomach because you can
put energy in this side in the form of
pollution and it creates electricity so
what is it it's got a microbial fuel
cell it's a little bit like a chemical
fuel cell which you might have come
across from school or you might have
seen in the news so chemical fuel cells
take hydrogen and oxygen and they could
combine them together and you get
electricity that's well established
technology it was in the Apollo space
mission that's from 4050 years ago
this is slightly newer this term
microbial fuel cell it's the same
principle
it's got oxygen on one side and instead
of having hydrogen on the other it's got
some soup and inside that suit there are
living microbes now if you take some
organic material could be some waste
products from food maybe the lives your
sandwich you put it in there the
microbes will eat that food and they
will turn it into electricity not only
that but if you select the right kind of
microbes you can use the microbial fuel
cell to treat some of the pollution it
reaches the right microbes the microbes
will eat algae if you use other kind of
microns they will eat or petroleum
spirits and crude oil so you can see how
this stomach could be used to not only
treat the pollution but also to generate
electricity from the pollution so the
robot will move through the environment
taking food into its stomach digest the
food create electricity use that
electricity to move through the
environment and keep doing this ok so
let's see what happens when we run the
robot when it does some rowing so here
we've got a couple of videos the first
thing you'll see hopefully you can see
here is the mouth open the front mouth
on the bottom mouth open and it all
stays opened enough and the robot will
start to row forward it moves through
the water so that food goes in as the
waste products go out what is moved
enough it stops and then it closes the
mouth and slowly closes the mouth and
then it will sit there and it will
digest the food
of course these microbial fuel cells
they can obtain microbes what you really
want is lots of energy coming out of
those microbes as quickly as possible so
we can't force the microbes and they
generate a small amount of electricity
per second they generate milli watts or
micro watts
now let's put that into context your
mobile phone for example with these
modern ones if you use it it takes about
one watt so that's a thousand or a
million times as much energy that uses
compared to the microbial fuel cell
there so how can we cope with that well
when the robot has done its digestion
when it's taken the food in it will sit
there and it will wait until it is
consumed all that food that could take
some hours it could take some days so a
typical cycle for the robot looks like
this you open your mouth you move you
close your mouth and you sit there for a
while waiting
once you've digest your food then you
can go about doing the same thing again
but you know what that looks like a real
organism doesn't it looks like the kind
of thing we do Saturday night we go out
open our mouths fill our stomachs
cinerender tele and digest oK we've had
enough we do the same thing again okay
now if we're lucky with this cycle at
the end of the cycle we'll have enough
energy left over for us to be able to do
something else we could send a message
for example because then the message
saying this is how much pollution I've
eaten recently or this is the kind of
stuff that I've encountered or this is
where I am now that ability to send a
message saying this is where I am is
really really important if you think
about the oil slicks that we saw before
or those massive algal blooms what you
really want to do is put your robot out
there and eats up all of those
pollutions and then you have to go
collect them why because these robots at
the moment this rather have got here it
contains motors it contains Y's it
contains components which themselves are
not biodegradable current robots contain
things like toxic batteries you can't do
those in the environment so you need to
track them and then when they finish
their job of work you need to collect
them at limits the number of robots you
can use now it's on the other hand you
have a robot a little bit like a
biological organism
it comes at the end of its life it dies
and it degrades to nothing so wouldn't
it be nice if these robots instead of
being like this method applies
affirmative other materials which when
you throw them up there and biodegrade
to nothing so that changes the way in
which we use robots instead of putting
ten or a hundred hours into the
environment having to track them and
then when they die
collect them you could put a thousand a
million a billion robots into the
environment just spread them round you
know that at the end of their lives
they're going to degrade for nothing you
don't need to worry about them so that
changes the way in which you think about
robots and the way you deploy them so
then the question is can you do this
well yes we have shown that you can do
this you can make robots which are
biodegradable and what's really
interesting is you can use household
materials to make these biodegradable
robots I'll show you something you might
be surprised you can make a robot out of
jelly so instead of having a motor which
we have at the moment
you can make things called artificial
muscles artificial muscles are smart
materials you play electricity to them
and they contract with a vendor they
twist they look like real muscles so
instead of having a motor you have these
artificial muscles and you can make
artificial muscles out of jelly you take
some jelly and some salts and do a bit
of jiggery-pokery you can make an
artificial muscle we've also shown you
can make the microbial fuel cells
stomach out of paper so you can make the
whole robot out of biodegradable
materials so you throw them out there
and they degrade to nothing well this is
a really really exciting this is going
to totally change the way in which you
think about robots but also it allows
you to be really creative in the way in
which you think about what you could do
with these robots I'll give you an
example if you can use jelly to make a
robot now we eat jelly right so why not
make something like this
a robot gummy bear okay so here I've got
some I prepared earlier there we go a
little packet and have a lemon flavoured
one and I take this gummy bear he's not
robotic okay we have to pretend and what
you do with one of these is you put it
in your mouth on lemon squad lunch
I project you it too much the robot may
not like it then you swallow it
oh and then it goes into your stomach I
went inside your stomach it moves its
thing it twists it bends it does
something it could go further down into
your intestines find out whether you've
got some ulcer or cancer maybe do an
injection something like that you know
that once it's done its job of work
it could be consumed by your stomach or
if you don't want that it could go
straight through you into the toilet and
be degraded safely in the environment so
this changes the way again in which we
think about robots so we started off
you're looking at robots that would eat
pollution and then we're looking at
robots which we can eat I hope this
gives you some idea of the kind of
things we can do in future robots thank
you very much for your attention